This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If we've learned anything from watching the turnover of tech giants like Yahoo and My Space, it's that internet, darlings rise and fall, and there's something darkly fascinating about watching it happen in real time. Maybe we're seeing it now with Twitter and Facebook. Some of us will mourn the loss of the communities and connections that we've created in the virtual spaces owned by these billion dollar companies. While others of us will
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果我们从雅虎和MySpace等科技巨头的兴衰中学会了什么，那就是互联网宠儿终会起落，而实时见证这一过程有着某种阴暗的迷人之处。也许我们现在正在推特和脸书身上目睹这一切。我们中的一些人会哀悼在这些价值数十亿美元公司所拥有的虚拟空间中建立的社区和联系的丧失。而我们中的另一些人则会
enjoy visiting the graves of these once unstoppable behemoths to tramp the dirt down. Either way, the values and trends and hopes and ambitions that go into the architecture of the virtual world say as much about us as the architecture of the real world. And that's what these two stories from 99 P.I.s past are all about. They are a couple of my absolute favorites. Enjoy. If there's one sound that instantly transports me back in time, it's this one, the dial-up modem tone.
乐于造访这些曾经不可一世的庞然大物的坟墓，去践踏那里的尘土。无论如何，构建虚拟世界架构所蕴含的价值观、趋势、希望和抱负，与现实世界的架构一样，都能反映出我们自身。这正是《99% Invisible》过去这两期故事的主题。它们是我最喜欢的几期节目中的两期。请欣赏。如果有一种声音能瞬间把我带回过去，那就是拨号上网的调制解调器声。
It reminds me of being in grad school in 1994. I was talking to one of my thesis advisors about the worldwide web and how much cool stuff was on there and how distracting it was, and he recommended that I take the weekend to go through the whole thing and get it out of my system. The internet was so new that a person with a PhD thought you could literally finish it in one weekend. For me, the dial-up tone reminds me of being a kid in the early 90s. When I thought the internet was just that thing
它让我想起1994年读研究生的时光。当时我正和一位论文导师谈论万维网，谈论上面有多少酷东西，以及它是多么让人分心。他建议我利用周末时间把整个网络浏览一遍，好让自己“戒掉”这种瘾。互联网当时太新了，以至于一位拥有博士学位的人竟然认为你真的可以在一个周末内把它看完。对我来说，拨号上网的声音让我想起90年代初还是个孩子的时候。那时我以为互联网只是
that my older tech savvy cousins logged on to the L.It strangers. Now, it's that thing that everyone logs on to the L.It strangers. That's Millennial producer Vivian Le. It's weird to think about because I, along with probably the rest of you, have been spending about 97% of my waking life on Slack, or Twitter, or Netflix, or Google Docs, but I'm just old enough to remember a time before the internet was a requirement to participate in society.
我那些精通技术的表亲们用来登录……（音频中断）……陌生人的东西。现在，它是每个人都用来登录……（音频中断）……陌生人的东西。那是千禧一代制作人薇薇安·勒。想到这一点很奇怪，因为我和你们其他人一样，醒着的时间里大约97%都花在Slack、推特、网飞或谷歌文档上，但我还足够老，记得互联网成为参与社会活动的必要条件之前的时光。
A time before it was everywhere. It was this new thing that you heard about. I first heard about the internet. This is David Bonette. I was reading a magazine, I think, PC World or something like that. And I just thought, oh, this just sounds amazing. Today, David's a philanthropist and tech entrepreneur.
在它无处不在之前的时光。那是一个你听说过的新鲜事物。我第一次听说互联网……这是大卫·博内特。我想我当时正在读一本杂志，可能是《PC World》之类的。我当时就想，哦，这听起来太棒了。如今，大卫是一位慈善家和科技企业家。
But back in the early 1990s, he really wanted to do something great with this thing called the World Wide Web, because the way he saw it, it was about to change the world for the better. David and his business partner, a guy named John Resner, decided in order to be a part of this digital revolution, they would found an internet company that hosted websites. The plan was straightforward enough. David and John would provide the online space and some basic tools so that individuals or companies could build their own web page.
但在90年代初，他真的很想用这个叫“万维网”的东西做点伟大的事情，因为在他看来，它即将让世界变得更美好。大卫和他的商业伙伴，一个叫约翰·雷斯纳的人，决定为了参与这场数字革命，他们要创办一家托管网站的互联网公司。计划很简单。大卫和约翰将提供在线空间和一些基础工具，以便个人或公司可以建立自己的网页。
And the company would host those pages on its servers. And because their office was based in Beverly Hills, they named their company Beverly Hills Internet. It will go down as having one of the worst names in history. Actually, Beverly Hills Internet was doing okay at first. It was starting to get some visitors to its website, but John and David found it difficult to get the kind of sustainable traffic that they really wanted, mostly because of one huge early 90s problem. What is internet? What is internet is that massive computer network, the one that's becoming really big now.
公司会将这些页面托管在服务器上。因为他们的办公室设在比弗利山庄，他们就把公司命名为“比弗利山庄互联网”（Beverly Hills Internet）。它将作为历史上最糟糕的名字之一被载入史册。事实上，比弗利山庄互联网起初做得还不错。它的网站开始有一些访问者了，但约翰和大卫发现很难获得他们真正想要的持续流量，这主要是因为90年代初的一个巨大问题。什么是互联网？互联网就是那个巨大的计算机网络，现在变得非常大的那个。
What do you mean that's big? How does one, what do you write to it like mail? Allison, can you explain what internet is? A lot of people didn't really get what internet was. Nobody really understood, at the time, what it meant to create a worldwide web of these kinds of connections where all computers were talking with one another and sharing information. So I had the challenge both trying to explain to my friends what I was trying to do and the wider world at the same time. Even though today the internet is woven into our everyday lives, it wasn't that long ago
你说的“大”是什么意思？你怎么用它，你是怎么给它写信的？艾莉森，你能解释一下什么是互联网吗？很多人真的不明白什么是互联网。当时没人真正理解，创建一个连接所有计算机并共享信息的万维网意味着什么。所以我面临的挑战是，既要向朋友解释我在做什么，又要同时向更广阔的世界解释。尽管今天互联网已经融入了我们的日常生活，但就在不久前，
that people had to make this enormously from a world with essentially no internet, to try to conceptualize what a globally-connected computer network meant, or what they would even do with it. Before search engines like Google, or social networks, or apps, the web seemed like this confusing, nebulous blob of information. It was a strange new technology that was hard to wrap our brains around.
人们还必须从一个基本没有互联网的世界中做出巨大的跨越，去尝试构思一个全球互联的计算机网络意味着什么，或者他们能用它做什么。在谷歌这样的搜索引擎、社交网络或应用程序出现之前，网络看起来就像一个令人困惑、模糊不清的信息团。这是一种奇怪的新技术，很难让我们理解。
Because David ran an internet company, his business dependent on users, having some grasp of what the internet was, so it was his challenge to get people comfortable on the web. There's got, you know, we need to develop, we need to come up with something more. He needed a hook. And one day in 1994, it just came to him. His hosting site didn't need a technological innovation.
因为大卫经营着一家互联网公司，他的业务依赖于用户对互联网的某种理解，所以他的挑战是让人们在网上感到舒适。他需要一个卖点。1994年的一天，灵感突然降临。他的托管网站不需要技术创新。
It needed a conceptual one. Users needed a new way of navigating the web. So we sketched out a plan to make his website feel more like a real neighborhood. You've got through what was a two-dimensional representation of a neighborhood, where you would see streets and blocks, and you would see icons that represented houses, and you would actually pick an address that you wanted to create your website, and you had a sense that you were joining a neighborhood.
它需要的是概念上的创新。用户需要一种导航网络的新方式。于是，他草拟了一个计划，让他的网站感觉更像一个真实的社区。你通过一个二维的社区表现形式，在那里你可以看到街道和街区，你可以看到代表房子的图标，你可以选择一个你想创建网站的地址，你会有一种加入了一个社区的感觉。
David didn't want people to think of the web as something you logged on to, but more like a physical place to dwell in, like a house. When you signed up for a new web page, that web page was your house in an online community of your choosing. This was all a new frontier and you were in a way of virtual homesteader. David and his team were endowing users with a sense of digital manifest destiny, one virtual neighborhood at a time. It was such a revolutionary idea that David and his partner decided to chuck out the whole Beverly Hills internet name and change their company to something that
大卫不想让人们认为网络是你登录的东西，而更像是一个可以居住的物理场所，就像房子一样。当你注册一个新网页时，那个网页就是你在你选择的在线社区中的房子。这都是一个新领域，你从某种意义上说是一个虚拟的拓荒者。大卫和他的团队正在赋予用户一种数字天命感，一次一个虚拟社区。这是一个如此革命性的想法，以至于大卫和他的合伙人决定抛弃“比弗利山庄互联网”这个名字，把公司改名为
fully leaned into these spatial metaphor they were creating. They called it geosities. The story of geosities is just a fantastic parallel for a real building, for something that was conceived of and created to model real life, but in the domain of cyberspace, and which ultimately had a catastrophic and dramatic fall in the end. This is James Crawford, the author of Falling Glory, the lives and deaths of history's greatest buildings. Geocities was not a physical place, but he included it in his book because the way he
完全契合他们正在创造的这种空间隐喻的名字。他们称之为“Geocities”（地球村）。Geocities的故事是一个关于真实建筑的绝佳类比，它是为了模拟现实生活而构思和创造的，但在网络空间领域，最终却以灾难性和戏剧性的方式陨落。这是詹姆斯·克劳福德，著有《陨落的荣耀：历史上最伟大建筑的生与死》。Geocities不是一个物理场所，但他把它写进了书里，因为在他
sees it, it was inhabited like one. That was something that I think Geocities was really providing, was creating these communities and then conceptualizing them as places, as places you could go as neighborhoods on the net. So you could be a citizen of a city, of a country, and you could then be a netizen of somewhere like geosities. The website was a collection of metropolises, each with their own neighborhoods built around shared interests. There was a region called Heartland where you could discuss tractor models or Pittsburgh where you could talk endlessly about your cats. Or in Area 51, you could find page after page after page of fan tributes to Dana Scully.
看来，它像一个地方一样被居住着。我认为Geocities真正提供的是创造这些社区，并将它们概念化为地方，作为你可以去的地方，作为网络上的社区。所以你可以成为一个城市、一个国家的公民，然后你也可以成为像Geocities这样的地方的“网民”。该网站是多个大都市的集合，每个大都市都有围绕共同兴趣建立的社区。有一个叫“心脏地带”（Heartland）的区域，你可以在那里讨论拖拉机模型；或者在“匹兹堡”，你可以无休止地谈论你的猫。或者在“51区”，你可以找到一页又一页关于丹娜·斯卡利的粉丝致敬页面。
As soon as David established this specialized version of the web, JuCities really began to click for people. David remembers how in the early days, he set up a little alert to go off anytime someone registered for a new account. So I'd be sitting in my office and we'd go dang, and someone would say, what's that? And I would say, well, somebody just registered for their own page of juicities, and they said, oh, that's cool. Then it would go dang.
大卫一建立这个专门版本的网络，Geocities就开始受到人们的欢迎。大卫记得在早期，他设置了一个小提醒，每当有人注册新账户时就会响起。所以我坐在办公室里，它会发出“叮”的一声，有人会问，那是什么？我会说，哦，有人刚刚注册了他们自己的Geocities页面，他们说，哦，那很酷。然后它又会“叮”的一声。
And then it really started to take off. just registered for their own page of geosities. And they said, oh, that's cool. Then it went like dang. And then it really started to take off. Ultimately, it was just non-stop. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. I mean, it was just, it was really, really exciting. You know, I would start to hear like, I mean, this is happening a lot. And so of course, I had turned it off
然后它真的开始起飞了。刚刚注册了他们自己的Geocities页面。他们说，哦，那很酷。然后它又“叮”的一声。然后它真的开始起飞了。最终，它简直是没完没了。叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。我的意思是，这真的、真的太令人兴奋了。你知道，我开始听到，我的意思是，这发生得太频繁了。所以当然，我不得不把它关掉，
because it was too disruptive. David wanted users who built their web pages and geocities to feel like part of a community. That, no matter how obscure their interests were, they could find a neighbor who felt just as passionately as they did about Star Trek or 12th century Norse mythology. I think a lot of that comes from my own experiences as a gay man and coming out and meeting other lesbian and gay people
因为它太吵了。大卫希望在Geocities建立网页的用户能感受到社区的一部分。无论他们的兴趣多么冷门，他们都能找到一个对《星际迷航》或12世纪北欧神话同样充满热情的邻居。我想这很大程度上源于我作为一名男同性恋者的个人经历，出柜并结识其他女同性恋和男同性恋者，
and understanding the power of meeting others of your own identity. I think people came to it with more open minds and less desire to be performative in how they would interact online. It was this fleeting moment when users see more interest in making human connections and honest self-expression than in cultivating a web persona. They just wanted to build something. They wanted to build something dedicated to Dana Scully. I was looking to give everybody the tools to create their own content and celebrate the terrific diversity and richness and tapestry of content created by users.
并理解结识与你有相同身份的人的力量。我认为人们带着更开放的心态来到这里，减少了在网上互动时进行表演的欲望。这是一个短暂的时刻，用户似乎对建立人际联系和诚实的自我表达比培养网络人设更感兴趣。他们只是想建造点什么。他们想建造一些专门献给丹娜·斯卡利的东西。我当时想给每个人提供工具来创造他们自己的内容，并庆祝用户创造的内容所具有的惊人的多样性、丰富性和挂毯般的质感。
There were, of course, some limitations to user-generated content. Geocities was a website that was built by amateurs, and it showed. The color palettes of most geocities pages seem like they were chosen randomly, or maybe even chosen with the intention of making them illegible, like neon green text over a neon yellow background. There were under construction signs twinkling star backgrounds, grainy low-res family photos, welcome to my homepage gifs, or gifs of dancing babies. You know, it was the Wild West, just different styles
当然，用户生成的内容也有一些局限性。Geocities是一个由业余爱好者建立的网站，这一点显而易见。大多数Geocities页面的配色方案看起来像是随机选择的，甚至可能是为了让人看不清而选择的，比如霓虹绿文字配霓虹黄背景。有“施工中”标志、闪烁的星星背景、颗粒感十足的低分辨率家庭照片、“欢迎来到我的主页”的GIF，或者跳舞婴儿的GIF。你知道，那是蛮荒西部，只是不同的风格
and different page layouts and different menus bars and even experimenting with menus and pages that were only menus. There was an absolute session with Comic-Sones font, you know, all these kinds of things, flashing gifts, all these things that are almost feel like a kind of early vomitess of the internet. Looking back to the lands of the flat design and
和不同的页面布局，不同的菜单栏，甚至尝试使用只有菜单的菜单和页面。当时对Comic Sans字体有一种绝对的痴迷，你知道，所有这些东西，闪烁的GIF，所有这些感觉几乎像是互联网早期呕吐物的东西。回顾后来出现的扁平化设计和
minimalism that came after, it's hard to click through these pages without having a chuckle. It was a whole lot messier and much more chaotic, but the pages built on Geoseries reflected this amazing moment when people were attempting to figure out what the internet was and what it could be. It's this beginning of the creation of web culture. And that's what's so interesting, it's the beginning of personal website. It's translating your life, who you are,
极简主义，很难在浏览这些页面时不发出轻笑。它要混乱得多，也杂乱得多，但建立在Geocities上的页面反映了人们试图弄清楚互联网是什么以及它能成为什么的那个惊人时刻。这是网络文化创造的开端。这就是最有趣的地方，这是个人网站的开端。它在翻译你的生活，你是谁，
and putting it online. By 1998, geocities was the third most visited website on the internet, just after Yahoo! Yahoo! line. By 1998, geosities was the third most visited website on the internet just after Yahoo. In fact, Yahoo was so impressed with geosities rapid ascent that they bought the company from David. Executives at geosities believed that combining forces with Yahoo would put the website on steroids. But that wasn't what most geocities users wanted. Users had legitimate concerns that,
并把它放到网上。到1998年，Geocities是互联网上访问量第三大的网站，仅次于雅虎。事实上，雅虎对Geocities的迅速崛起印象深刻，以至于他们从大卫手中买下了这家公司。Geocities的高管们认为，与雅虎联手会让网站如虎添翼。但那并不是大多数Geocities用户想要的。用户有合理的担忧，
you know, geocities will lose its independence and its identity, which is ultimately what happened. After the purchase, geocities users woke up to a notice saying they had to re-register. Granting Yahoo, the rights to? The royalty free, perpetual, irrevocable, not exclusive, and fully sub-lessonsable right, and lessons to use,
你知道，Geocities会失去它的独立性和身份，而这最终也确实发生了。收购后，Geocities用户醒来时看到一则通知，说他们必须重新注册。授予雅虎权利去？免版税、永久、不可撤销、非排他性且可完全分许可的权利，以及使用、
reuse, revive, adapt, publish, translate, create derivatives from, distribute, perform, and display such content in all over part, worldwide, and or to incorporate it in other works in any form, media, or technology, no, no, or they're developed. Meaning all of the content on the website would now be owned by Yahoo. Many threatened to leave the city in protest. And as a result of that, Yahoo actually agreed to alter their
再利用、修订、改编、发布、翻译、创作衍生作品、分发、表演和展示此类内容的许可，全部或部分，在全球范围内，和/或以任何形式、媒体或技术将其纳入其他作品中，无论现在还是未来开发。这意味着网站上的所有内容现在都归雅虎所有。许多人威胁要抗议离开这个城市。结果，雅虎确实同意修改他们的
signaled just the very beginning of the end. It was the beginning of the end, not just for geocities, but for a ton of internet companies around the web. The dot-com bubble had been rapidly inflating throughout the late 90s because investors were pouring money into internet startups left and right, and just crossing their fingers that one day they'd be profitable. There was actually a mantra that you weren't a successful dot-com company unless you were losing money. By the year 2001, the bubble had burst,
这标志着终结的开始。这不仅是Geocities的终结，也是网络上大量互联网公司的终结。互联网泡沫在整个90年代末迅速膨胀，因为投资者不断向互联网初创公司投入资金，只是祈祷有一天它们能盈利。当时甚至有一种口号，说如果你不亏钱，你就不是一家成功的互联网公司。到2001年，泡沫破裂了，
in corporations like Yahoo, or losing their footing. The internet was starting to change fast. Up until this point, a lot of users have been working in a static entry-level version of the internet. It was more homemade, identifiable by those vibrant, personal pages hand-built by users. It's where geosities had thrived. But by the time the new millennium rolled around, the internet was evolving into a whole new experience.
像雅虎这样的公司也失去了立足点。互联网开始迅速改变。在此之前，许多用户一直在使用静态的入门级互联网。它更像家庭作坊，以用户手工制作的那些充满活力的个人页面为标志。那是Geocities蓬勃发展的地方。但当新千年到来时，互联网正在演变成一种全新的体验。
This internet was based around interactive social networking sites. You would punch in your name, age, and relationship status, and the site would spit out a manicured profile page. Users were encouraged to write on each other's walls and tag and comment. Geocities had created this great spatial metaphor to help people understand the web, but users were out growing that metaphor. Having a geocities page began to feel embarrassing to a lot of users, which is basically a death
这个互联网基于交互式社交网站。你输入你的名字、年龄和恋爱状态，网站就会吐出一个精心修饰的个人资料页面。用户被鼓励在彼此的墙上留言、标记和评论。Geocities创造了这个伟大的空间隐喻来帮助人们理解网络，但用户已经超出了那个隐喻。拥有一个Geocities页面开始让许多用户感到尴尬，这基本上是任何平台的死
sentence for any platform. I can't shake up my geocities account. Hold on. Oh, no. Let me crank up the computer. Let me crank up the computer. No, no, no, no. I'll need more. Hey, don't need more.
刑。我无法摆脱我的Geocities账户。等等。哦，不。让我启动电脑。让我启动电脑。不，不，不，不。我需要更多。嘿，不需要更多。
I suppose because we're so close to it, and we know the people who created these. You know, maybe there are parents, maybe there are older brothers or sisters. And we don't necessarily respect it. Yahoo! Stocks started to plummet shortly after about geosities. And year after year, the site was losing more users. From a business perspective, geocities seem like dead weight.
我想是因为我们离它太近了，我们认识创造这些东西的人。你知道，也许是父母，也许是哥哥姐姐。我们不一定尊重它。雅虎的股票在收购Geocities后不久就开始暴跌。年复一年，该网站流失了越来越多的用户。从商业角度来看，Geocities看起来像是死重。
July 2009, they send what they call a service announcement. And all it says is that geocities is closing and all files are going to be deleted from servers and will not be recoverable. Geocities was about to be completely wiped out, as if it had never existed. You know, even if you look at something like the dropping of a nuclear bomb, that still leaves ruins, it still leaves people, you know, those people can then grow something from the ashes. This is an absolute existential deletion of existence, you know, it has just taken and it is gone. This was the whole sale destruction of a website that changed the way that people looked at the internet.
2009年7月，他们发布了所谓的“服务公告”。上面只写着Geocities即将关闭，所有文件都将从服务器上删除，且无法恢复。Geocities即将被彻底抹去，仿佛它从未存在过。你知道，即使你看看像投下原子弹这样的事情，那仍然会留下废墟，仍然会留下人，你知道，那些人可以从灰烬中成长。这是一种绝对的存在性删除，你知道，它只是被拿走了，然后就消失了。这是对一个改变了人们看待互联网方式的网站的全面销毁。
A lot of people believe that these pages deserve to be saved. And a handful of people decided to actually do something about it. There's this sense always that like the web is permanent. Like if you do something terrible, it's on the internet forever. And if you have one embarrassing photo and someone shares it, it'll never go away. And I'm here to tell you that now it'll probably all go away. This is Jason Scott. Jason actually has a few roles.
很多人认为这些页面值得被保存。少数人决定真正采取行动。人们总有一种感觉，认为网络是永久的。就像如果你做了什么可怕的事情，它会永远留在互联网上。如果你有一张尴尬的照片，有人分享了它，它就永远不会消失。但我在这里告诉你，现在它很可能会全部消失。这是杰森·斯科特。杰森实际上有几个角色。
He's a digital archivist, historian, software curator, angel of death. So the reason I'm known as the angel of death is because I have successfully let people know that when a certain kind of situation happens, call Jason Scott. The situation is that a website is on the brink of its demise. And all of its digital information is about to be lost forever. Jason's job is to swoop in and download all of that data before it's gone for good. And like the angel of death, Jason's face is the last thing that a dying website sees before it's gone for good. Back in 2009, before he became the go-to savior of the old web. Jason was noticing more and more
他是数字档案管理员、历史学家、软件策展人、死亡天使。所以我被称为“死亡天使”的原因是，我已经成功地让人们知道，当某种情况发生时，给杰森·斯科特打电话。这种情况就是网站处于灭亡边缘。它所有的数字信息都即将永远丢失。杰森的工作是在它彻底消失之前冲进去下载所有数据。就像死亡天使一样，杰森的脸是垂死的网站在彻底消失前看到的最后一样东西。早在2009年，在他成为旧网络的首选救星之前，杰森就注意到越来越多
that old school hosting services like Geocities were going dark. He couldn't stop thinking about all the user-generated content that was being destroyed in the process. The one that still haunts me is this woman who in 1994 made an entire website in HTML about her child who had died when he was two, and she's got
像Geocities这样的老派托管服务正在变暗。他无法停止思考在这个过程中被销毁的所有用户生成内容。最让我难以忘怀的是一位女士，她在1994年用HTML制作了一个关于她两岁时去世的孩子的完整网站，她有一个
a little, you know, candle gif and a little MIDI song playing in the background, and this was her story. Jason wanted to make sure sites like Jews, cities and their data weren't just erased. So we connected with a group of like-minded digital preservation enthusiasts scattered around the world, and they drafted a plan. Somebody should come in. There should be an A-Team, an archive team that rushes in and makes a copy. Wouldn't that be something? So we announced that we're an archive team.
小小的、你知道，蜡烛GIF，背景里播放着一首小小的MIDI歌曲，这就是她的故事。杰森想确保像Geocities这样的网站及其数据不会就这样被抹去。所以我们联系了一群志同道合的数字保存爱好者，他们散布在世界各地，他们起草了一个计划。应该有人介入。应该有一个A队，一个冲进去并进行备份的档案团队。那不是很好吗？所以我们宣布我们是一个档案团队。
We're going to rescue your s***, and that was our slogan. We're going to rescue your s***. Archive team decided their mission was to keep an eye out for websites in danger of being shut down. The ones that they say are on Death Watch and download every piece of data they could before that site goes dark. Their goal is to preserve digital heritage no matter how small. In their first project, geocities. For us it was worth it because we hate Yahoo. But it wasn't solely about saying up yours to Yahoo!
我们要拯救你们的垃圾，这就是我们的口号。我们要拯救你们的垃圾。档案团队决定他们的使命是留意那些面临关闭危险的网站。他们称之为“死亡观察”，并在网站变暗之前下载他们能下载的每一条数据。他们的目标是保存数字遗产，无论它有多小。他们的第一个项目是Geocities。对我们来说，这是值得的，因为我们讨厌雅虎。但这不仅仅是为了对雅虎说“去你的”。
Okay, well that was a very big part of it, but it was also about something bigger. I also wanted people to kind of get knocked in the head about the impermanence of digital information, that it was both brittle and easily lost, but also with a little bit of care, easily saved and kept. Our Cive team had a dual mission in addition to preserving things. They also want us to understand that digital information is fragile. The profiles you build on any social media site, the videos you upload to YouTube, they all exist out of your hands and on some
好吧，那确实是其中很大一部分，但它也关乎更宏大的事情。我还想让人们意识到数字信息的无常性，它既脆弱又容易丢失，但只要稍微用心，也很容易被保存和保留。档案团队除了保存东西外，还有双重使命。他们还想让我们明白数字信息是脆弱的。你在任何社交媒体网站上建立的个人资料，你上传到YouTube的视频，它们都存在于你无法控制的地方，在某些
corporation servers, and they can vanish at any given moment. They have no idea that it can literally, literally disappear in a week or a day, and it just comes to it and there's an error and it's gone, and I get to see that over and over and over again. So that's, you know. I'm delighted that they're making these worlds, and I'm cynical about how long they last. Yahoo! Had hinted in early 2009 that it would be closing down the service sometime later that year.
公司的服务器上，它们随时可能消失。他们根本不知道它真的、真的会在一周或一天内消失，它只是发生了错误，然后就没了，我一次又一次地看到这种情况。所以，你知道。我很高兴他们在创造这些世界，但我对它们能持续多久持怀疑态度。雅虎在2009年初暗示它将在那年晚些时候关闭该服务。
So geocities could have maybe a few months or a few days. Parkive team got to work immediately trying to recruit as many people as possible to help with what Jason referred to as GeoCities Download a Paloosa. I started using whatever social media capital I had at the time, and about 200, I think 300 people in total came in and it was really lumpy. They have their computers crawling Yahoo servers to pull out any piece of public Geocities data they could get. We were just doing it day in and day out and saying, okay, who wants to take this part over,
所以Geocities可能还有几个月或几天的时间。档案团队立即开始工作，试图招募尽可能多的人来帮助杰森所说的“Geocities下载狂欢”。我开始利用我当时拥有的任何社交媒体资本，大约有200，我想总共有300人加入了，这真的很零散。他们让他们的电脑爬取雅虎服务器，以提取他们能得到的任何公共Geocities数据。我们只是日复一日地做这件事，说，好吧，谁想接手这一部分，
who wants to do this part? Let's look for this. Let's do searches on the web for every noun in the dictionary. Try to find every Geocities site that mentions any noun, and then try to compile them into a unique set and then assign it to people to download. Then on October 26, 2009, after six months of work, the day they all dreaded finally came. Archive team watched from their respective computers as the digital city slowly went offline for good. Jason said that watching Yahoo pull the plug was like something out of 2001 a space odyssey.
谁想做那一部分？让我们找找这个。让我们在网上搜索字典里的每一个名词。尝试找到每一个提到任何名词的Geocities网站，然后尝试将它们编译成一个独特的集合，然后分配给人们去下载。然后，在2009年10月26日，经过六个月的工作，他们最担心的那一天终于来了。档案团队从各自的电脑上看着这个数字城市慢慢地永远下线。杰森说，看着雅虎拔掉插头就像《2001太空漫游》里的情节。
It is exactly like shutting down how. And we will be like, this set has gone down, they've now powered down this server, they've now powered down this server. Archive team was still working as fast as possible to grab whatever Geocity's data was left, while the servers went dark one by one. Well, like, here it goes. We just lost this one, we just lost this one,
这就像关闭哈尔（HAL）一样。我们会说，这个站点已经下线了，他们现在关闭了这个服务器，他们现在关闭了那个服务器。档案团队仍在尽可能快地工作，以抓取剩下的任何Geocities数据，而服务器一个接一个地变暗。好吧，就像，它来了。我们刚刚失去了这个，我们刚刚失去了那个，
keep going, keep going. And we're just going until finally, it's just not responding meaningfully at all. I mean, that's pretty much the ending of every one of these stories. It's us packing up the boxes, putting them on the pallets. So it's this pride that we got the job done, but it really feels like we lifted a piano up 20 stories and then took it down again 20 minutes later.
继续，继续。我们只是不停地做，直到最后，它根本没有任何有意义的响应。我的意思是，这几乎是每一个故事的结局。是我们打包箱子，把它们放在托盘上。所以这是一种我们完成了工作的自豪感，但感觉就像我们把一架钢琴抬上20层楼，然后20分钟后又把它搬下来。
Yep, we were good piano movers. But it wasn't all for nothing. In the end, ourive team managed to extract a terabyte of data from geosities. And as it turns out, there were multiple parallel projects that were downloading geosities data. A lot of them have sent their data to Jason for safe keeping. All together, Archive team saved more than a million accounts from Deletion. Archive team wanted to bring some attention to their work, so they took all of that Geocities data they'd preserved, and they turned it into a torrent on the pirate bay.
是的，我们是很好的钢琴搬运工。但这并非毫无意义。最终，档案团队成功地从Geocities提取了一TB的数据。事实证明，有多个并行项目在下载Geocities数据。他们中的许多人把数据发给了杰森保存。总共，档案团队从删除中拯救了超过一百万个账户。档案团队想让人们关注他们的工作，所以他们拿走了他们保存的所有Geocities数据，并把它做成了海盗湾上的一个种子。
The pirate bay is generally used for illegally downloading games, movies, and software, so no one really saw this coming. You're like, we have the hottest new wear for you. Here's GeoCities. And it was the largest torrent at its time. It broke everything. And when it got uncompressed, it turned out windows machines couldn't handle it. People were furious because it's
海盗湾通常用于非法下载游戏、电影和软件，所以没人预料到这一点。你就像，我们有最热门的新软件给你们。这是Geocities。它是当时最大的种子。它破坏了一切。当它被解压时，结果发现Windows机器无法处理它。人们很愤怒，因为这
terrible. Like, why am I doing this? It's telling me I have, you know, 19 months to download surely it's some sort of top secret, you know, allocation of information of the darkest parts of the web. And it's like, no, it's cats. And it's lots of rock, enrol, fan sites.
太糟糕了。就像，我为什么要这样做？它告诉我，你知道，我有19个月的时间来下载，这肯定是某种关于网络最黑暗部分的绝密信息分配。结果发现，不，是猫。还有很多摇滚乐粉丝网站。
And it's families telling you that they're gonna have a barbecue. Jason wasn't sure what people would actually do with the geosities data, but that really wasn't his concern. He just wanted to make sure that it was safe and available to anyone who wanted it, and maybe, if he was lucky, something useful would come out of it down the line. I long to go got out of the argument of what good is this. Actually, a number of people have downloaded the geosities, Torrent, and it made some really cool projects with that data.
还有家庭告诉你他们要举行烧烤。杰森不确定人们会用Geocities数据做什么，但这并不是他关心的。他只是想确保它是安全的，并且对任何想要它的人可用，也许，如果他幸运的话，以后会有一些有用的东西出来。我很久以前就放弃了“这有什么用”的争论。事实上，很多人下载了Geocities种子，并用这些数据做了一些非常酷的项目。
A good amount of geosities pages have been restored, and you can browse through them online. Since saving geosities, Jason and the archive team have preserved a number of dying websites around the internet from Yahoo groups to Justin.tv. It's all accessible on a digital archive called Wayback Machine, where you can find over 477 billion saved web pages. The Wayback Machine was founded by the Internet Archive, or Jason Scott, is now an archivist. A lot of time and energy went into rescuing geocities, along with a ton of other archaic sites
相当多的Geocities页面已经恢复，你可以在线浏览它们。自从拯救了Geocities，杰森和档案团队已经保存了互联网上许多垂死的网站，从雅虎群组到Justin.tv。这一切都可以在一个名为“Wayback Machine”的数字档案中访问，在那里你可以找到超过4770亿个保存的网页。Wayback Machine由互联网档案（Internet Archive）创立，或者说杰森·斯科特现在是一名档案管理员。很多时间和精力都花在了拯救Geocities上，还有大量其他古老的网站
from this generation of the web. But I want to be clear, none of this was salvaged as examples of how well the web worked back in the day. No one needs more net scape now buttons or Backstreet Boys fan pages. I think we're good on Backstreet Boys fan pages. The point is, these archives should be studied because our web history is our history, no matter how goofy it might appear.
来自这一代网络。但我想要明确一点，这些都不是作为当时网络运行得多么好的例子被抢救出来的。现在没人需要更多的Netscape“导航”按钮或后街男孩粉丝页面。我想我们已经有足够的后街男孩粉丝页面了。重点是，这些档案应该被研究，因为我们的网络历史就是我们的历史，无论它看起来多么滑稽。
If the internet's history were sketched to look like the march of progress, that famous illustration charting human evolution with an ape on one side and a man on the other, geosities would be like that third guy from the right, a little hairy, a little clumsy, but definitely an important link that made us what we are today. I mean, it's not necessarily art,
如果互联网的历史被描绘成进步的步伐，就像那幅著名的图表，一边是猿猴，另一边是人类，Geocities就像从右边数第三个人，有点多毛，有点笨拙，但绝对是让我们成为今天这样的重要环节。我的意思是，它不一定是艺术，
but it's absolutely culture. James Crawford again. You know, this is what we've all was done as humans. You know, going back to the earliest marks we put on the caves is you're presented with a surface and what do you do with it? How do you mark it? How do you represent who you are on that space? And a number of people have made this comparison between the cave paintings of last goal and what was happening on geocities, and it seems like a bizarre, almost absurd comparison to make.
但它绝对是文化。再次引用詹姆斯·克劳福德的话。你知道，这就是我们人类一直以来所做的。你知道，回到我们在洞穴上留下的最早标记，你面对一个表面，你会用它做什么？你如何标记它？你如何在那片空间里代表你是谁？很多人把拉斯科洞穴壁画和Geocities上发生的事情进行了比较，这看起来是一个离奇的、几乎荒谬的比较。
But actually, if we fast forward another 10,000 years and look back, that's absolutely what it was. It was people grappling with a new technology and how to represent their humanity in that space. You can imagine thousands of years from now. Pass the boundary of the cringey recent past to a future human, dusting off an old PC desktop from 1997, finding a geocities torrent, and taking an anthropological exploration
但实际上，如果我们再快进一万年回头看，那绝对就是它。这是人们在努力应对一种新技术，以及如何在那片空间里代表他们的人性。你可以想象几千年后。越过令人尴尬的近期边界，未来的某个人，掸掉1997年的旧PC桌面，找到一个Geocities种子，并进行一次人类学探索，
of what's inside. So the first thing they're going to do is just waste a week trying to figure out if they're getting the colors wrong. Like they they're gonna look at these backgrounds, and they're gonna be like, this is objectively illegible, and they're gonna check the specs, check the specs, and go, nope, those people had no taste. What was going on there? And the answer was, the sky was the limit.
看看里面有什么。所以他们要做的第一件事就是浪费一周时间试图弄清楚他们是否把颜色搞错了。就像他们会看着这些背景，然后他们会说，这客观上是无法辨认的，他们会检查规格，检查规格，然后说，不，那些人没有品味。那里发生了什么？答案是，天空才是极限。
So, why not? Yellow on pink. Why not? Blinking text, saying that this is your home page and then an animated gif with three frames of a waving care bear right next to your description of, you know, love for Jesus. This future person is going to discover a tiny window of web history where people were trying their best to chart a course through completely unknown territory. Where users took chances and weren't ashamed to look a little messy or garish or hopeful.
所以，为什么不呢？粉色上的黄色。为什么不呢？闪烁的文字，说这是你的主页，然后是一个动画GIF，有三帧挥手的关爱熊，就在你描述你对耶稣的爱旁边。这个未来的人将发现一个微小的网络历史窗口，人们在那里尽最大努力在完全未知的领域中规划航线。用户冒险尝试，并不羞于看起来有点凌乱、花哨或充满希望。
They're going to see this boundless joy of people who are unfettered by feeling that they have to sell themselves to present their best faces. And they'll see a lot of lies, a lot of truth, a lot of honesty, but it's going to come from a person talking to you because geocities made it easy to work in the code of the web, but it didn't teach you to be a performer. So that's what they're going to find. And they're not going to believe it.
他们会看到人们那种无限的快乐，他们不受必须推销自己以展示最好一面的感觉的束缚。他们会看到很多谎言，很多真相，很多诚实，但这将来自一个与你交谈的人，因为Geocities让你很容易使用网络代码，但它并没有教你成为一个表演者。所以这就是他们会发现的东西。而且他们不会相信。
They're going to assume this was all a trick. Nobody could be this nice. Nobody could be this forward. No one could be this personal, but they were. We have another story about aocities. Hey Viv. Hello, how are you? I'm good. I'm good. So one of the reasons why we do these code is we have all this stuff that's on the cutting room for that doesn't quite fit into the story, but it's so good that we just want to talk about it. So let's talk about it. So something that we kind of alluded to in the main piece, but didn't really spend a
他们会认为这都是一个骗局。没有人能这么好。没有人能这么直接。没有人能这么个人化，但他们确实是。我们还有另一个关于Geocities的故事。嘿，薇薇。你好，你好吗？我很好。我很好。所以我们做这些节目的原因之一是我们有所有这些在剪辑室里的东西，它们不太适合故事，但它们太好了，我们只是想谈谈。所以让我们谈谈吧。所以我们在主篇中提到了一些，但并没有真正花
lot of time getting into was the afterlife of the Geosities data that was saved by archive team. Right. So we kind of focused on like the life, death, and preservation of geosities. But we didn't really dip into what people have done with it afterwards because the story kind of felt complete on its own, but there's a lot there. Right, right. So what are people making with this geocities data? Probably one of my favorite projects is this website called camminsworld.net, which was created by this web designer named Cameron Askin.
很多时间深入探讨的是被档案团队保存的Geocities数据的来世。对。所以我们有点专注于Geocities的生、死和保存。但我们并没有真正深入探讨人们之后用它做了什么，因为故事本身感觉很完整，但那里有很多东西。对，对。那么人们用这些Geocities数据制作什么？我最喜欢的项目之一可能是这个叫camminsworld.net的网站，它是由一位名叫卡梅伦·阿斯金的网页设计师创建的。
And I don't really know how to describe it other than saying it's like, it's like everything that the Space Jam website wishes it was. Like I don't even, like I really don't know how to explain it, but it's just a really cool way to kind of click through and view old Geo City's pages. And like there's this theme song that loops around that's been playing in my head for like the last two months. Like it's great. So you should definitely look at it. Another website that's worth checking out is called deletedcity.net which is this awesome interactive map created by a designer named Richard Vigen where you could browse through the geosaties neighborhoods as if they're like neighborhoods on it like a city grid.
我真的不知道怎么描述它，只能说它就像，它就像《空中大灌篮》网站希望成为的一切。就像我甚至，就像我真的不知道怎么解释，但它只是一个非常酷的方式来点击浏览和查看旧的Geocities页面。而且有一个循环播放的主题曲，在过去两个月里一直在我脑海里回荡。就像它很棒。所以你一定要看看它。另一个值得一看的网站叫deletedcity.net，这是一个由设计师理查德·维根创建的超棒的交互式地图，你可以在那里浏览Geocities社区，就像它们是城市网格上的社区一样。
So it's really cool to be able to zoom in and see it like if it were an actual city, this is what it would look like. That's cool. That's cool. But one project that I really want to talk about is called One Terabyte of the Killabite Age. And it was created by two people named Oliya Liyalina and Dragon Espinsheet. And it's an archive of almost 400,000 Geosities pages. And I originally spoke with Oliya for the piece because she had
所以能够放大并看到它，如果它是一个真实的城市，它看起来会是这样，这真的很酷。那很酷。那很酷。但我真正想谈的一个项目叫“一TB的千字节时代”（One Terabyte of the Kilobyte Age）。它是由两个名叫奥利亚·利亚利纳和德拉贡·埃斯平希特的人创建的。它是一个包含近40万个Geocities页面的档案。我最初为这篇文章采访了奥利亚，因为她有
this really interesting relationship with Geosities and the old web because she was a webmaster and web design professor back in like the mid 90s. And she told me that she used to save web pages like the ones in geosities so she could show her students examples of like how not to build a good web page. Like don't use like twinkling star backgrounds or a million of the colors or those under construction signs that are never taken off. Yeah, yeah, yeah, like don't do this. I see.
这种与Geocities和旧网络非常有趣的关系，因为她在90年代中期是一位站长和网页设计教授。她告诉我，她过去常常保存像Geocities那样的网页，这样她就可以向学生展示如何“不”建立一个好的网页。比如不要使用闪烁的星星背景，或者一百万种颜色，或者那些从未被取下的“施工中”标志。是的，是的，是的，就像不要这样做。我明白了。
But, you know, she said that she was noticing the shift from, you know, Web 1.0 to Web 2.0 in real time towards the end of the late 90s in the beginning of the early 2000s, because it was getting a lot harder for her to find like the twinkling star backgrounds or the welcome to my homepage gifs. You mean homepage gifs? Gifs. Home page gifs. Like we're not gonna start this right now. Okay, keep going. But like, you know, because she started seeing that they're like disappearing, she really started to study these things and like really love the design of the early web because of what it represented. Because of very, reasons, I started to collect them, just in all safe graphics.
但是，你知道，她说她实时注意到了从Web 1.0到Web 2.0的转变，在90年代末和21世纪初，因为她发现像闪烁的星星背景或“欢迎来到我的主页”GIF变得越来越难了。你是说主页GIF？GIF。主页GIF。我们现在可不开始这个。好吧，继续。但就像，你知道，因为她开始看到它们正在消失，她真的开始研究这些东西，并因为它们所代表的东西而真正爱上了早期网络的设计。因为各种原因，我开始收集它们，只是在所有安全的图形中。
And it was not because I thought at the time that you should archive the web, or you can have some historic significance. But then I realized that it's not just some that's some funny websites I disagree with, but visions of how the worldwide web should be. They are getting changed. So when the GeoCities TORN got released on the Pirate Bay, Oli and Dragon like immediately downloaded it and have been studying it ever since, but what I really like about the work that they're doing is that this is not a nostalgic exercise. They're really looking at what these early web elements can teach us about our relationship with the web in the 90s and early 2000s. Like if you look at something like the under construction sign, for example. On the construction sign, it's not just a funny picture.
这并不是因为我当时认为你应该归档网络，或者它具有某种历史意义。但后来我意识到，这不仅仅是一些我不同意的有趣网站，而是关于万维网应该是什么样子的愿景。它们正在发生改变。所以当 GeoCities TORN 在海盗湾发布时，Oli 和 Dragon 立即下载了它，并从那时起一直在研究它。但我真正喜欢他们所做的工作的一点是，这不仅仅是一种怀旧练习。他们真正着眼于这些早期的网络元素能教会我们关于 90 年代和 21 世纪初我们与网络的关系。比如，如果你看看“施工中”标志之类的东西。施工标志不仅仅是一张有趣的图片。
It's not just a symbol for the old website, but I tried to explain what does it mean exactly, why is it important? So basically, the under construction sign was a symbol for this moment when the web was being hand-built by amateur users. And there was this general acceptance that a website could be a work in progress. You could take your time, and it was okay for people to get a glimpse of the building process before it was finished. But that all changed with the introduction of Web 2.0 because more professional web
它不仅仅是旧网站的象征，我试着解释它到底意味着什么，为什么它很重要？基本上，“施工中”标志象征着这样一个时刻：当时网络是由业余用户亲手构建的。人们普遍接受网站可以是一个“进行中”的作品。你可以花时间，人们也能在它完成之前瞥见构建过程，这没关系。但随着 Web 2.0 的引入，这一切都改变了，因为更专业的网络
designers were taking over and big social networking sites were taking over. On the construction sign was really the first one that the professional designers started to remove from the website because over how can it be that it's something is not ready. Huh. I never thought about that before. Like the disappearance of the under construction sign really signaled this move towards a
设计师接管了网站，大型社交网站也接管了网络。“施工中”标志确实是专业设计师开始从网站上移除的第一个元素，因为他们觉得怎么能让东西还没准备好呢。哈，我以前从没想过这一点。比如“施工中”标志的消失，确实标志着向
kind of corporate version of the internet. Yeah, that's what Oli believes. And like this is just a one aspect of how geosities is being studied. But I thought this was cool because projects like this basically show that it's possible to apply some sort of like archeological lens to this website that a lot of people wrote off is useless. Yeah, I mean, it totally makes sense to me. I mean, that you would tell us what we were thinking at
一种企业版互联网的转变。是的，这就是 Oli 的观点。这只是 GeoCities 被研究的一个方面。但我认为这很酷，因为像这样的项目基本上表明，有可能对这个被许多人视为无用的网站应用某种考古视角。是的，我的意思是，这对我来说完全说得通。我的意思是，你会告诉我们当时我们在想什么，
the time that you needed to put up a site so badly, like within 10 minutes that you had to put an under construction sign on there. But you might take with it or you might just leave it, you know, like, you're not. Yeah, why not. So tell me her project's name again. So it's called one terabyte of the kilobyte age. That's such a good name. I mean, people should definitely check that out because it's like they'll have a whole new appreciation for under construction signs. And what we think of is ugly graphics that really made the wet wood is today. Yes, exactly. The whole time that we were putting this piece together, I was reminded of this story that I did originally for stamp judgment, but we played it on 9 MPI before about the you know, the destruction of an online community, which was also a really sad story in many ways.
以至于你如此迫切地需要建立一个网站，在 10 分钟内就不得不放上一个“施工中”标志。但你可能会带着它，或者你可能只是把它留在那里，你知道，你不是。是的，为什么不呢。那么再告诉我一次她的项目名称。它叫“千字节时代的 1TB”。这名字真好。我的意思是，人们绝对应该去看看，因为他们会对“施工中”标志有全新的认识。而我们认为丑陋的图形，正是造就了今天网络的原因。是的，完全正确。在我们制作这段节目的整个过程中，我一直想起我最初为《Snap Judgment》制作的一个故事，但我们之前在 99% Invisible 上播放过，关于你知道的，一个在线社区的毁灭，在很多方面这也是一个非常悲伤的故事。
And so I wanted to just like attach it here to play it for you. So you can do it. I love the story. Here it is. A few months before the end of the world, Paul Monaco posted this message on YouTube. Hello, everyone.
所以我只是想把它附在这里播放给你听。你可以听听。我喜欢这个故事。给你。在世界末日的前几个月，Paul Monaco 在 YouTube 上发布了这条消息。大家好。
Paul Monaco here, Buddha Paul, his most few. Know me as, you probably all heard the news, Ye land, the sims online, closing down. The world that was ending was called The Sims Online. It was an online version of one of the most popular computer games ever made. You've all been wonderful. You helped me through a hard time in my life
我是 Paul Monaco，Buddha Paul，大多数人认识我。你们可能都听到了新闻，EA Land，《模拟人生在线》要关闭了。那个即将终结的世界叫做《模拟人生在线》。它是史上最受欢迎的电脑游戏之一的在线版本。你们都很棒。在我生命中一段艰难的时期，你们帮助了我，
when I first got online. But ironically, the online version of The Sims was not very popular. They ended up losing tons of subscribers and changing the name to EA Land, and then they finally pulled the plug. Thank you, and that, please. Let's try to stay in touch.
当我第一次上网时。但讽刺的是，《模拟人生》的在线版本并不是很受欢迎。他们最终失去了大量的订阅者，并将名称更改为 EA Land，最后他们终于拔掉了插头。谢谢你们，就这样，请保持联系。
And if not, go back with whatever you choose to do and move on to. As you can probably hear, EA Land is not a normal video game. There are no monsters, no killing, and although it had some competitive elements, for many players, competition wasn't the point at all. Unlike a lot of other games where you might be shooting people or slaying dragons or something, this is a game about socializing. That's Robert Ashley. And Robert Ashley? He produces a very popular and fantastic internet radio show that's been on a very long hiatus.
如果不行，那就继续做你选择做的事，继续前进。正如你可能听到的，EA Land 不是一个普通的游戏。没有怪物，没有杀戮，虽然它有一些竞争元素，但对许多玩家来说，竞争根本不是重点。不像许多其他游戏，你可能会射击别人或屠龙之类的，这是一个关于社交的游戏。那是 Robert Ashley。而 Robert Ashley？他制作了一个非常受欢迎且精彩的互联网广播节目，该节目已经停播了很长时间。
And the creator of a life well wasted. A life well wasted. It's about video games and the people who love them. An EA Land was a video game that a dedicated few absolutely loved. The crowd that attracted, I think, were people who just wanted to get together and sort of chat, meet strangers. It was a nice place. Over time, it became a kind of intimate, almost bar, like the cheers of video games. Where everyone knows your name,
他是《A Life Well Wasted》的创作者。《A Life Well Wasted》。它是关于电子游戏和热爱它们的人。EA Land 是一款被少数忠实玩家绝对喜爱的电子游戏。我认为它吸引的人群只是想聚在一起聊天、结识陌生人。那是一个不错的地方。随着时间的推移，它变成了一种亲密的、几乎像酒吧一样的地方，就像电子游戏界的《欢乐酒店》。在那里每个人都知道你的名字，
and at the moment that Paul Monaco, aka Buddha Paul, found EA Land, it was exactly what he needed most. My wife had a long-term illness, she from a blood transfusion, she had hepatitis C. And the last three years or so of her life were pretty, pretty much a challenge for both of us. And after she passed away, I had absolutely no function other than the wake-up
而在 Paul Monaco，也就是 Buddha Paul，发现 EA Land 的那一刻，这正是他最需要的。我的妻子患有长期疾病，她因为输血感染了丙型肝炎。她生命中最后三年左右的时间对我们俩来说都是一个巨大的挑战。在她去世后，我除了起床、
go-to-work and go to sleep again. With her illness, I didn't get out and socialize much. We weren't able to, you know, go out to the bars and meet up with friends and have dinner. I totally dessocialized myself. And this game was kind of a way for me to just kind of get back into into living again. It was it was pretty amazing. And Paul began to live for a year land.
上班和睡觉之外，完全没有任何功能。因为她的病，我没有出去社交太多。我们无法，你知道，去酒吧和朋友见面吃晚饭。我完全把自己与社会隔绝了。而这个游戏对我来说是一种重新开始生活的方式。这真是太神奇了。于是 Paul 开始为 EA Land 而活。
He would play it for hours and hours. It was the first thing he did when he got home from work. You treated to a big warm greeting, everyone would say hi, and your high-end would be beeping along, and you'd be inundating with that. It made you feel really good. It wasn't the real world, but his friends were real friends. In virtual worlds, do have an upside.
他会玩上好几个小时。这是他下班回家后做的第一件事。你会受到热烈的欢迎，每个人都会打招呼，你的好友列表会一直闪烁，你会沉浸在其中。这让你感觉非常好。这不是现实世界，但他的朋友是真实的朋友。在虚拟世界中，确实有积极的一面。
You're a race, you're a college religion, all that can be totally masked and you're truly judged on who you really are and how you present yourself. There's no prejudice, there's no preconceived anything. You're really taking a face value. People could really like break loose and in and be themselves and have some fun. It just feels really good. But Paul's utopia didn't last because E.A.L.A. and started hemorrhaging money. The writing was on the wall, the surbra was about to go dark. In this event, this virtual apocalypse might only exist in the memory of the players.
你的种族、你的大学宗教，所有这些都可以完全被掩盖，你真正被评判的是你真实的样子以及你如何展示自己。没有偏见，没有先入为主的任何东西。你真的是按面值被对待。人们真的可以释放自我，做回自己，享受乐趣。这感觉真的很好。但 Paul 的乌托邦并没有持续下去，因为 EA Land 开始亏损。大势已去，服务器即将变黑。在这个事件中，这种虚拟的末日可能只存在于玩家的记忆中。
If it weren't for Dr. Henry Lowwood. I had just stumbled across this project by Henry Lowwood. My name is Henry Lowwood, who is this archival researcher at Stanford. And I had a project called How They Got Game, which is on the history of digital games and simulations, saving video games for future generation. You know, 50, 100, 200 years from now, how are we gonna save that history? You know, like, we've gotta save the video games.
如果不是因为 Henry Lowwood 博士。我偶然发现了 Henry Lowwood 的这个项目。我叫 Henry Lowwood，是斯坦福大学的一名档案研究员。我有一个项目叫“他们是如何获得游戏的”，关于数字游戏和模拟的历史，为后代保存电子游戏。你知道，50、100、200 年后，我们将如何保存那段历史？你知道，我们必须保存电子游戏。
So Dr. Loewood and his colleagues preserve what happens inside video games. Now, for a single-player game like Pac-Man, for example, this is easy. You effectively take out the Atari cartridge and put it on the shelf. But saving multiplayer online games is not so simple. Saving the software alone is kind of a barren exercise.
所以 Lowwood 博士和他的同事们保存了电子游戏内部发生的事情。现在，对于像《吃豆人》这样的单人游戏，这很容易。你实际上取出 Atari 卡带并把它放在架子上。但保存多人在线游戏并不那么简单。仅仅保存软件是一种贫瘠的练习。
If you save the code for Eiland and turn it on 100 years from now, you'd enter a world and nothing would be there. All the things that Paul Monaco and his friends love would be impossible to find. You need to document what people are doing in these spaces. That situation is much more like what a historian on archivists would do when faced with the problem of documenting the real world. So when Dr. Lowood caught wind of the Eale land shutting down, he had the opportunity to record something a historian or archaeologist would die to witness firsthand in the real world. To see what it would be like when an online world came to an end. archaeologists would die to witness first hand in the real world.
如果你保存了 EA Land 的代码并在 100 年后打开它，你进入一个世界，里面什么都没有。Paul Monaco 和他的朋友们所喜爱的一切都将无法找到。你需要记录人们在这些空间里在做什么。这种情况更像是一位历史学家或档案管理员在面对记录现实世界的问题时会做的事情。所以当 Lowwood 博士听到 EA Land 即将关闭的消息时，他有机会记录下历史学家或考古学家在现实世界中梦寐以求亲眼见证的事情。看看当一个在线世界终结时会是什么样子。考古学家梦寐以求亲眼见证现实世界中的事情。
To see what it would be like when an online world came to an end. What happens when a virtual world closes? The end of a culture. What is it like to be there in the last minute when it shuts down? So the tape is rolling in the last few hours via land or being recorded, and the most dedicated die hard users are there exchanging virtual hugs and reminiscing. The players are typing messages that appear like comic book word bubbles.
看看当一个在线世界终结时会是什么样子。当一个虚拟世界关闭时会发生什么？一种文化的终结。在它关闭的最后一分钟身处其中是什么感觉？所以录音带在 EA Land 的最后几个小时里一直在转动，最忠实的铁杆用户在那里交换虚拟拥抱并回忆往事。玩家们正在输入像漫画书气泡一样出现的文字信息。
You hear all these avatars cry. And you also hear all the coos and moans in the gibberish language of the game known as simlish. And you know, they sound like they're going to be bombed and everything, but it's not like a big pity party. But then toward the end of the night, there's this radio station that you can listen to in the game called Charmed Radio. And they had the CJ there named Spike. He is sort of the only voice that you end up hearing at the end of the world.
你听到所有这些化身在哭泣。你还会听到游戏中被称为“模拟语”的胡言乱语中的咕哝声和呻吟声。你知道，他们听起来好像要被炸毁了，但这不像是一场盛大的同情派对。但在深夜临近时，游戏里有一个你可以收听的广播电台，叫“Charmed Radio”。他们有一个叫 Spike 的 DJ。他算是你在世界末日时唯一能听到的声音。
And as soon as he starts talking, you understand what is being lost. Hey guys, the last time you're going to hear me speak, well, the last time before TSO goes down. I just want to thank you all, it's been an amazing experience it really has and I'd probably say I wouldn't mind myself crying but I can't. I can't stress enough how much you guys have meant to me over the past however many years it's been. It really has been awesome ad. Some people don't get attached to things but when you make friends, I look people living this game. It's actually really hard. So we're playing the last song. It's Sarah Brightman and Andrea Bacheli.
一旦他开始说话，你就明白正在失去什么。嘿伙计们，这是你们最后一次听到我说话，嗯，在 TSO 关闭之前的最后一次。我只想感谢你们所有人，这是一次了不起的经历，真的。我可能会说我不介意自己哭出来，但我不能。我怎么强调你们在过去这些年里对我的意义都不为过。这真的很棒。有些人不会对事物产生依恋，但当你结交朋友时，我看着人们生活在这个游戏中。这实际上非常困难。所以我们正在播放最后一首歌。是 Sarah Brightman 和 Andrea Bocelli 的。
Time to say goodbye. Hopefully you guys will like. It means that tomorrow's my Yahoo ID is 1-2-3-4-5-2-1. Are you alright? 1-2-3-4-5. You're lucky lucky life everybody and Best wishes. I love you all and that's been great knowing you Take care guys and
《Time to Say Goodbye》。希望你们会喜欢。这意味着明天我的 Yahoo ID 是 1-2-3-4-5-2-1。你还好吗？1-2-3-4-5。祝大家好运，万事如意。我爱你们所有人，很高兴认识你们。保重，伙计们，还有
Let's just I just want to Even if you haven't go to drink this proposal toast to Parasad who's been absolutely amazing Parasad we can have done this without you. Thank you Absolutely amazing powers that we can have done this without you. You get this feeling like being on the deck of the Titanic. Anyone who actually stayed to the end was very much invested in the game on an emotional level. When they pulled the plug on the server, knits and pieces of the world started to disappear. The environment began to disintegrate. The texture on the trees flickered, and all the people froze, in blanks out of existence.
让我们，我只是想，即使你没有去喝这杯提议的祝酒词，敬 Parasad，他绝对太棒了。Parasad，没有你我们无法做到这一点。谢谢，绝对太棒了，没有你我们无法做到这一点。你会有种身处泰坦尼克号甲板上的感觉。任何真正坚持到最后的人都在情感层面上对游戏投入了极大的感情。当他们拔掉服务器的插头时，世界的碎片开始消失。环境开始瓦解。树木上的纹理闪烁，所有人都冻结了，然后消失在虚无中。
The actual ending was, you know, not with a bang, with a whimper. And the last thing that they saw was basically just an error message, a server disconnect message. And then, the world ended. That story was originally produced for the great public radio show Snap Judgment in 2010, based off a story from the podcast A Life Well Wasted, which after a nine-year hiatus released a new episode at the end of 2022. It was marvelous to have it back. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week By Vivian Le, Original Episode Mixed by Bryson Barnes,
真正的结局，你知道，不是一声巨响，而是一声呜咽。他们看到的最后一件事基本上只是一个错误信息，一个服务器断开连接的信息。然后，世界终结了。那个故事最初是为 2010 年的伟大公共广播节目《Snap Judgment》制作的，基于播客《A Life Well Wasted》中的一个故事，该播客在停播九年后于 2022 年底发布了新一集。它能回来真是太棒了。《99% Invisible》本周由 Vivian Le 制作，原始剧集由 Bryson Barnes 混音，
Remixed by Martin Gonzalez, Music by Swan Rial. Jalenti Hollis, our Senior Editor, Kurt Colstead, is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmet Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Chris Barube, Jason D'Aleon, Lashima Dohan, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Sofia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his below-go was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Olya Lialina. You can find a link to her project,
由 Martin Gonzalez 重新混音，音乐由 Swan Rial 创作。Jalenti Hollis 是我们的高级编辑，Kurt Colstead 是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括 Emmet Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Chris Barube、Jason D'Aleon、Lashima Dohan、Jacob Maldonado Medina、Joe Rosenberg、Kelly Prime、Sofia Klatsker 以及我 Roman Mars。《99% Invisible》的标志由 Stefan Lawrence 创建。本周特别感谢 Olya Lialina。你可以在我们的网站上找到她项目的链接，
One Terabyte of the Killabite Age on our website. James Crawford's book is called Fallen Glory, The Lives and Deaths of History's Greatest Buildings. Geosidoses is just one small section of that book. There are a ton of other fascinating stories about lost and ruined buildings. We'll have a link to that as well. 99% of visible is part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family. Now headquartered to Six Blocks North in the Pandora building.
《千字节时代的 1TB》。James Crawford 的书名为《Fallen Glory, The Lives and Deaths of History's Greatest Buildings》。GeoCities 只是那本书的一小部分。还有很多关于失落和废弃建筑的迷人故事。我们也会提供相关链接。《99% Invisible》是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于 Pandora 大楼以北六个街区。
And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 999 PI or court Instagram, Reddit and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99nipei.org. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，风景优美。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars 和 @99PI 关注我，也可以在 Instagram、Reddit 和 TikTok 上关注。你可以在 99pi.org 找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。